this is bandit country
Lourdes and in some places almost likely
Gau in eastern Mali is a key stop on the
smuggling route north there's the
epicenter of a French led war against
terrorism
[Music]
RAF helicopters are helping them shift
troops and equipment around this region
they've been here a year now and they've
just had that stay extended by another
six months
there are four and a half thousand
French troops operating in this part of
northern Mali and they're fighting a
conflict against Islamic extremism
including Islamic state in West Africa
and al-qaeda this is a new hotbed of
terrorism and if not controlled it could
threaten Western Europe into all this
Britain will send 250 troops to join a
massive UN peacekeeping mission the
British will be operating in small teams
at long range and on their own they will
do to do a part of the heavy lifting
they will do operations in very
contentious areas they will do
operations where we have a great degree
of uncertainty they will do operations
where we face threats to us and not
since Bosnia will British forces have
done anything like this they will be the
tip of the spear and it won't be easy
the Malian government controlled the
capital Bamako but only just
thousands have escaped here from the
fighting and the surrounding countryside
it is one of the poorest cities in the
world
and has become a prison for huge numbers
of women trafficked here and forced into
prostitution and slavery
precious was tempted away from Nigeria
by empty promises of money she was freed
only a few days ago we met her in hiding
and she explained how they marked her to
stop her escaping traitor mine finger
knees that are the help of my public
parts for my ambition for my head
how's that for words in case even after
making the old I live her I don't use
that against me she shows us the bruises
on her legs
mr. Smee I think about the beatings
starving me to beat us if I good I think
so many we care thanks to you that when
she puts my head inside the buckets of
water for 30 minutes so just bits of a
landlord stop moans deeply she puts my
head I chase a bucket of water solar
treatment for tetanus all the bits of
the man that was that I don't dear Molly
is in a desperate state this is what's
happening and it is getting worse
Alistair bungle Sky News in Mali